let's see if we can write 1.50 one as a
percentage now we really just want to
write this quantity as something over
100 so what we can do is we can say that
this is the same thing as 1 point 5 0 1
over 1
we haven't change this value and let's
multiply it times 100 over 100 when we
do this product and I haven't changed
the value this is just multiplying
something times 1 but when we do it
we're going to change the way that we're
representing it the denominator now is
going to be 1 times 100 so that's pretty
straightforward that's just going to be
100 and then the numerator we're going
to want to multiply 1.50 1 times 100 and
so this is going if we multiply this
times 10 we would move the decimal 1
over we want to multiply it by 100 so we
want to multiply it by 10 again so we're
going to move the decimal over to the
right twice we're multiplying it by 10
twice or you're multiplying it by 100
this is multiplying by 10 this is
multiplying by 100 so this is where the
decimal is going to sit now so we're
going to get 150 point 1 and so we've
rewritten 1 point 5 0 1 is 150 point 1
over 100 or 150 point 1 per hundred let
me write that 150 point 1 per per
hundred which is the same thing as 150
point 1 percent which is the same thing
as 150 point 1 150 point 1 percent and
we're done and essentially all you're
doing if you really want to simplify the
process we're multiplying this by 100 to
get 150 point one and then we're saying
that is the percentage so you want to
make sure that you write the percent
there or the percent symbol